what's going on and reject nation it's
Greg Alva here I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch today a video that
Andrew hast sent over to us over at
patreon Andrew Hayes actually has his
own movie review channel and he does
some great reviews on there he's a he's
a fun guy
loud he's enthusiastic and hey you do
that perfectly just gotta go up at the
end gotta go up at the end you nail it
like you have the right subtlety what do
you do and one of our patron reward
tiers if you qualify is whatever video
you request we must definitely do and
put up on the channel and today he has
requested the top 10 movies of all time
from watchmojo.com this video actually
came out in 2014 of March does this
account for future films yeah this will
probably be one of the best ways you
know and then the year 3000 this is
gonna come out thanks Andrew Hayes
you're a great guy because no new movie
can be one of the best of all time we're
counting down our picks based on tasty
burger this final video culminates our
best movies of all time great power fly
drawing from the number 1 or number 2
point O in each decade these movies are
selected based on their iconic status
again pocalypse now really united stand
this reminded we go and every minute
charlie squats in the bush he gets
stronger with cinema legends like Martin
Sheen Robert Duvall and Marlon Brando
and the lead roles Apocalypse Now
crackles with scene after scene of
horrifically and masterfully executed
death and destruction this is not an
easy movie to sitting Joseph Conrad's
Heart of Darkness Francis Ford Coppola
is gritty oscar-nominated Vietnam war
epic follows a group of soldiers tasked
with assassinating a rogue right they
told me totally insane but the result is
less a journey about the horrors faced
in the trenches and more about the
shadows of the soul
[Music]
after feeding we're not in Kansas
anymore
number nine The Wizard of Oz yeah with
Alfred Baum's universally appealing
stories its backbone this Technicolor
masterpiece transcends age and race to
tell the coming-of-age story of a young
Kansas girl and dreams of a land
somewhere over the rainbow I'm the
Scarecrow this wasn't a success it makes
no great film we should do is do full
movie reviews after the video go on with
the wounded easiest six and a half hours
with a strong female heroine winning a
record number of Oscars including a
lemon I think for african-american
actress Hattie McDaniel oh she won huh
ultimately when all its romance and
heartbreak Gone with the Wind is a
cinematic landmark that won't soon be
forgotten
comeback Shawshank I hope they don't
ruin it this few is I haven't seen the
Shawshank Redemption parts of this
carted off to jail for his wife's
watching the host lady frame but rather
than being a tale of despair and
hopelessness it's a story of fortitude
friendship fidelity and of course
redemption it was like some beautiful
bird flapped into our travel cage and
made those walls dissolve away and for
the briefest of moments every last man
in show David probe Valley's my sister's
Godfather's Freeman working together to
bring the story to life do this Frank
Darabont film was not a runaway
box-office hit of course not positive
reviews eventual popularity and seven
Academy Award nominations ensured its
spot in cinema history
I do that every time it rains
except for Angie Martin here for six the
dark night not present in most comic
book movies this second film in
Christopher Nolan's Batman franchise
redefined the genre and appealed to both
comic-book fans and the general public
[Music]
same Joker Dark Knight where's the lines
between superhero and super villain
painting each as a complex and embattled
character with a standout Heath Ledger
performance that one the actor of
posthumous Oscar Batman story was given
a decisively gritty sequel and one that
surpassed the original why so serious
[Music]
fuzzball number five Empire episode 5
the Empire Strikes Back
while the first film in George Lucas's
Star Wars saga was a fun space adventure
the second is much darker and more
emotional considered by many as the
strongest of the three original films
Empire principles out of the eyes with
its expensive and extravagant visuals
it's also a timeless story to which we
can all relate aside from the distant
planets lightsabers and alien creatures
that is innovative and creative this
chapter in the life of Luke Skywalker
and Friends is epic filmmaking at its
finest
everything under we all go a little mad
sometimes Bates Motel high more pretty
high where does look like Alfred
Hitchcock's shower incident with its
many cuts many angles this is how I'd
want to go out like a relaxing a way to
go out play the rest of psycho would be
fatal
this thriller is Hitchcock's masterwork
since find that it's better especially
with that masturbation but even if you
know the secrets of psycho
it says terrifying as ever concentration
[Music]
yes so one place he knew we can hide
something crazy how many stars actually
in this movie Quentin Tarantino's
oscar-winning cult fiction is driven by
subtle articulate and pop-culture heavy
dialogue
they call the Big Mac not only to hear
plot follows an interwoven group of
colorful characters in intricate detail
with such dark humor you'll laugh in
spite of yourself all right
say something somebody with a sounded
punctuates the mood and sound bites
he'll be quoting for years pulp fiction
has everything necessary to make you
watch it over and over
my name is dawn d camera cut Sir Michael
Caine this is the most entertaining
movie ever
I wonder what'll be number one
Casablanca or The Godfather or the
Welles co-wrote directed produced and
starred in this film which tells the
life story of a wealthy media flashbacks
I expect to lose a million dollars next
year you know mr. Thatcher at the rate
of a million dollars a year I have to
close this place in 60 years to create
his oscar-winning identities wells
employed innovative and groundbreaking
cinematic Edgar Wright Ellington yes I
get right huh
[Music]
[Laughter]
before we unveil our pick for the best
movie of all time yeah yeah are a few
honorable mentions nations are correct
this baby it's one of the most beloved I
think matters features one of the best
movies of all time oh it's gonna be The
Godfather
it's an honorable magic they're a comic
movie in here is this it is this the
Godfather could be cutting light on the
Mafia world like few films before or
since
the Best Picture winning Godfather
follows the Corleone family I think I
found a part to better love Godfather
one but I think part is better Francis
Ford Coppola cracks a world that allows
us to care for and even identify with
men who are fundamentally bad guys a
little a bit of a gamble and virtuoso
performances by greats like Brando
Pacino and Duvall elevate the summer
right now with better violence to make
the guy
holy great film leave the gun take the
cannoli okay do you agree with our list
what's your favorite movie of all time
for more thrilling Top Chef right 2000s
Space Odyssey isn't on there and a
matrix actually it's not the matrix
might have been it crept in somewhere
deep in the woods I mean my favorite
thanks for the list WatchMojo thanks
I've been on your second and first
choice was so not predictable
I heard it on every film I mean 30 wrong
The Godfather is amazing amazing film
and still holds up amazingly I love that
film to me Godfather Part 2 is the more
preferred one I there's an argument to
me for what's better yeah I think it has
a better pace the thing that holds
Godfather two back as you would need to
see Godfather one to really grasp what
God loves you is a strong like the
strengths of it yeah what are the rules
can you be one of the best if you're a
sequel dependent on what came before
only the Dark Knight is true that but
does the Dark Knight work as its own
film yeah I think it does yeah in a
different way from the Godfather I feel
like The Godfather chooses film the same
thing with the Dark Knight where you can
watch those without seeing the first
ones but there's less impact I feel
emotional impact if you don't have the
prior investment in the history of what
came before it's like watching Logan
like Logan I think works great on its
own but if you haven't seen a few of the
x-men films there's missing impact
you'll miss years worth arses yeah I
mean Godfather Part 2 that won best
picture as well it's the only film where
the first and second one both won Best
Picture and the third was robbed and
Vito and Vito Corleone II performance by
DeNiro also won it's the only film role
in history were like a different actor
plays him yeah there and then they both
win Brando and DeNiro both win the film
has to in some ways be a better
experience if it's gonna win though
Awards - yeah it can't just be oh it's
just as good so here yeah
he's got a wuss yeah which me yeah must
yet unless it does something that's a
little better or all the other films had
to do significant defense in the year it
came out yeah it's only one great movie
this year well for my personal favorites
I mean I guess take the opportunity
lists movies that could be our personal
favorite I feel like Citizen Kane and
Godfather and I'm surprised Casablanca
was only an honorable mention three
always hear Godfather Casablanca Citizen
Kane those are the top three I always
hear it maybe they're trying to be a
little edgy the thing is like ten slots
and and they're still making movies and
so like at a certain point I feel like
it was the choice between now we're
making more movies than ever we will
never know what the best films of all
time are truly well when you do lists
like this you try to go by okay let's
get a film from a decade and what's the
most impactful film from that decade I
think what'll set a lot of people
likewise in Goodfellas on here well we
already have a mob movie so let's go
with Godfather anyway though my favorite
film I'm really surprised wasn't
mentioned on here even as an honorable
mention is the matrix yeah I was very
surprised by that because that movie it
was a cultural moment the maitre de
Mauro from a nil yeah the matrix is
approaching its 20th anniversary it's
still influenced had left an impact on
audiences and filmmakers alike it's one
of those movies kind of like Star Wars
where people were like the matrix a huge
inspiration for me it well has
everything yeah it has great
storytelling it has unique fictional
sci-fi exploration it's got the
philosophy it's got Keanu Reeves some
some of the effects feel a little dated
but then there's plenty of effects we
were like that's all looks great yeah
it's got one of the best Keanu Reeves
performance it's got memorable
characters you know there's no like
oscar-worthy performance the only one
who I felt could have gotten some type
of Austra
would have been Hugo Weaving there's an
argument I think to be made for Laurence
Fishburne his Morpheus that's the one I
would have thought yeah did choice
really yeah I feel like Hugo Weaving has
the calm manner that he's got scenes
were just kind of like losing his [ __ ]
on Morpheus yeah
yeah matrix has it all that was the
start of every freaking actor doing more
to get in shape and learn martial arts
you couldn't be old guy fat boy anymore
where you just pull your pants up real
high the days of Schwarzenegger are gone
because Schwarzenegger doesn't know how
to really fight he just don't said I'd
be bossed about woman who's cool for
today your time yeah not really fight
you gotta be tactical ripped and a good
at yeah or a passable actor anyway oh
yeah the matrix broke new grounds in
terms of what we can explore in movies
but then again it's like well well we
would have Empire Strikes Back on here
and if there was it for Star Wars it'd
probably have gone something like a
matrix down the road my other favorite
films are not I mean the Dark Knight's
one of my favorite films that's on this
list I really love the hell out of Drive
I don't think that what's ever gonna
make anyone's list ever us yeah yeah but
drive I I always consider one of my
favorite films you have at Edwards
Edwards are your number one favor right
we all love movies that are kind of just
movies but that's one I think is a film
and I don't think it would ever be
lauded as as one of the greatest but
it's pretty great and I think there's
plenty people actually consider one of
their favorites somebody told me once
that the year didn't Tarantino won Best
Screenplay for pulp fiction or Reservoir
Dogs that year fiction pulp fiction 19 I
believe he said it should have been
Atwood yeah yeah yeah which was one of
those stories that stuck with me of like
oh wow yeah it really is like a great
movie moment and it's a movie that I
guess it's kind of underappreciated
because my everybody knows who had what
is I feel like to do this list
thoroughly you kind of by this point
have to do like a top 50 like top 10
there's gonna be so many asterisks as to
how you have to put this together
because you guys think of cultural
impact and how long that impact sustain
and influence films over time yeah and
you gotta spread it across decades and
genres because I feel like Batman Begins
in the Dark Knight those two together
influenced a wave of sequels that are
darker yes even though Empire was like
the first one to really do that stamp it
was after dark night where everyone's
like let's go darker with our reboots
and our sequels
well that's the change in the business
to is now like once one thing works in a
big way everyone's like this is what
everyone want it until they stop paying
yeah that's what I think matrix should
be on here I mean Godfather evidently
influenced it I mean that's the ultimate
mob movie Goodfellas some might consider
that their favorite and in some ways
enjoyed Goodfellas more than the
Godfather I would say a my ranking of
mafia films would go Godfather to
Goodfellas Godfather one all of my top
five spots are Scarface it would be nice
to have a little bit more sci-fi on here
because sci-fi to me is one of the most
groundbreaking parts of what makes
cinema so special I was go ahead at
least to see that the honorable mentions
included both The Matrix and metropolis
cuz metropolis and back to the future
and back to the future yeah those are
all three I think contenders and
metropolis too in terms of older films
you watch that in it's breathtaking what
they were able to achieve so early on
and how much of that imagery is still
Apes and referenced pocalypse now really
everybody else does
that's a movie I saw and I was like I'm
glad I saw this I don't know if I ever
want to watch this again I don't know if
I'll ever be in the position yeah I
remember that experience is appreciated
such a dreary experience to sit through
you need to have your patient
appreciation goggles on I guess it is a
good choice and it's funny a couple of
bookends this list you are like yeah I
mean this is incredibly well realized
however again there are other war movies
I would much rather watch yeah and war
isn't my favorite genre anyway it's
about time we get a war combien yeah fun
more like a world war two about a
battalion I didn't see much action yeah
but they were out there still single
raised bastards the closest we'll get
yeah at least inglorious basterds has
like a popcorn satisfaction yeah adamant
and a certain fantasy about it yeah and
that will never be one of the greatest
films of all time it's probably the war
movie I would reach yeah
I'm surprised I'm surprised like maybe
Saving Private Ryan wasn't an honorable
mention because that's a beloved or
Schindler's List yeah in terms of war
not that's like a combat war movie but
it's still a war movie yeah Schindler's
List I'm actually now surprised didn't
make any part of this I don't hear any
Spielberg movies on this list yeah
which is surprising to me know Brooks
made a few okay movies and it's time you
know one or two and yes in there I think
would be the one burn him and I hear
people reference that movie more than
say Apocalypse Now but alright well
Andrew Hayes thanks for saying this this
way Andrew Hayes dude Andrew it's
Christmastime New Year's you know what I
hope your new year's resolution is I
hope you can have an orgy with two other
guys Matt beer did you know him and a
guy of your choosing guide your choosing
with your new girlfriend
yes cuz that will not lead to any
emotional complications whatsoever well
no if she just runs the camera it'll be
fine Oh POV yeah yeah yeah get one of
those hardcore Henry rate so that we're
watching this whole experience through
your eyes female oh good luck with your
with your new girlfriend okay I have one
right now when you get one this should
be show her this video and and then
hopefully you can convince her and yeah
I know most guys want one with another
girl
that's not you I pick up on the vibe I
wanna the whole community of different
types of people yeah that'd be cool
knock it all out in one day every type
of person how could I get all my
experiences knocked out at what and
we're gonna play all these movies in the
background cuz it's gonna be a long orgy
if you have that many people involved
subscribe you the real rejects click
that notification bell you can follow us
on patreon become a patron eject today
it's like a second youtube channel post
plenty over there also download and
follow us at the Stardust app we post
regularly over there as well almost at
three thousand followers join us join us